If you've ever wanted to know
what a revolution looks like,
feast your eyes on Manila tonight.
Marcos's regime ended in 1986
when he was toppled by what is now known
as the People Power Revolution.
The Filipino government has estimated
that the amount the Marcos family pilfered
was between $5 billion and $10 billion.
So this is just graft
on an absolutely massive unheard of scale.
Marcos declared martial law in 1972,
closed newspapers, jailed political foes,
turned parliament into a rubber stamp.
The Marcos regime was very
concerned about dissidence,
so the security forces are tasked
with arresting the dissidents,
torturing them for information.
Oftentimes, the victim
would be summarily executed.
A nation took to the streets tonight
to celebrate its victory.
A dictator had fallen. The
people conquered his palace.
Reagan, who was president at this time,
actually offered Marcos asylum in the U.S.
And so when Marcos did ultimately decide
to step down in February of 1986,
Reagan sent two planes to cart Marcos
and 90 members of his entourage,
along with millions of
dollars worth of loot.
It is time to come to an understanding
with both the government and Marcoses
to compensate the human rights victims.
In 1992, after years of building the case,
the Marcos class action
finally went to trial.
The jury in Hawaii ultimately
held Marcos responsible.
The judgment in total
was almost $2 billion,
which was astronomical.
It's been a long fight to this point,
but we're going to continue
to fight to the end.
We knew at the outset that it
was gonna be a very risky litigation.
At that point, what they
had was just a number
on a piece of paper and
actually turning it into money
for the class was gonna be
a much harder challenge.
My name is Haley Cohen Gilliland,
and I am an independent
journalist based in Los Angeles.
We cannot succeed without
the support of our people.
So Ferdinand Marcos ran the
Philippines for 21 years,
and he first blazed into
the presidency in 1965.
He was a remarkably charismatic figure.
He was a wonderful orator.
He had a beautiful wife
who was very elegant
and had a gorgeous singing voice,
and she would regale crowds
at his campaign rallies.
Now everybody seems to be involved
in the destiny not only of himself
but of the entire content
of the entire nation,
and this is what we have
been hoping and praying for.
His first term was really promising.
He invested really
widely in infrastructure
and urban beautification and
especially rural development,
and so his base of
followers grew and grew.
Then in his second term,
he started to run into some problems,
allegations of corruption,
growing poverty,
and simultaneously, some
separatist guerrilla groups,
violent groups, started
to pop up in the country.
Ferdinand Marcos at this
point takes advantage
of the advent of these
groups to declare martial law
and essentially rule
the country by decree.
I have received hundreds and hundreds
of telegrams from all
corners of the Philippines,
congratulating you and incidentally me
for the proclamation of martial law.
And all the while Filipino citizens
were being tortured and imprisoned,
the Marcoses would spend
really brazenly and lavishly.
So they amassed dozens
of luxury properties all
over the Philippines and around the world.
Then in 1986, Ferdinand Marcos
decided to call an election.
Marcos! Marcos!
By all accounts, Marcos
fixed that election,
and when that became clear,
that unleashed massive
protests around the country.
Millions of Filipinos
flooded into the streets,
demanding that Marcos step down.
And ultimately in that case,
the U.S. finally said, "Enough is enough,"
and encouraged Marcos
to step down as well.
But they didn't completely
cut support because Reagan,
who was president at this time,
actually offered Marcos asylum in the U.S.
And so when Marcos did ultimately decide
to step down in February of 1986,
Reagan sent two planes to cart Marcos
and 90 members of his entourage,
along with millions of
dollars worth of loot,
diamonds and cash,
some of which they carried
out in diaper boxes.
Reagan sent planes to cart
those people and assets
to Honolulu where Marcos
was welcomed with asylum.
My name's Robert Swift.
Most people call me Bob. I'm a litigator.
I do complex litigation,
and I've been doing that
for almost 48 years.
At the time of the revolution
in the Philippines,
there was a great deal
of publicity as well
as information that
various human rights groups
have collected about human
rights abuses committed
by the Marcos regime.
And my initial intention was
to bring individual cases,
but when I learned of the
enormity of the abuses,
I decided that it was worthwhile
to try bringing a class action.
And the way that he did that
was using this very rarely used statute
called the Alien Tort Statute,
and that statute was
first enacted in 1789.
It's only a couple of sentences,
but it essentially allows
non-U.S. citizens to sue people
for violations of
international law in U.S. court.
About 10,000 Filipino people signed on
to become a part of this class action,
which is absolutely a massive class.
It is time to compensate
the human rights victims.
The first named plaintiff
was a college-age girl
by the name of Lilioso Hilao.
She had written some
articles in the student press
which were not flattering to the Marcoses
or the Marcos regime.
She was arrested by military,
taken to a military detention center
where she was interrogated.
When she was uncooperative,
the military poured muriatic
acid down her throat,
and she died from asphyxiation.
Another example is an individual
by the name of Mariano Pimentel.
Pimentel had been a
political leader in Mindanao.
He'd been arrested several times.
He was finally released from detention
after more than six months,
and on his way back to his province,
military members in a Jeep stopped him,
took him to a sugarcane
field, had him dig a grave.
They then buried him up to his neck,
and before they filled in the soil,
they broke a leg and broke an arm
so that he wouldn't be
able to dig himself out.
They then put the soil back in
and buried him up to his neck
and they figured they would
let the ants do the rest.
He survived because there
were several children
who had been hiding in the sugarcane field
who saw him and dug him
out, and he later emigrated
to the United States where I met him.
In addition, the present
state has the duty
to uphold the need to
recompense its own victims.
In 1992, after years of building the case,
the Marcos class action finally
went to trial in Hawaii,
and the jury in Hawaii ultimately
held Marcos responsible
for the abuses and torture
that had occurred under his regime.
So in 1994, Swift asked
the jury for $1 billion,
which represented $100,000 per victim,
which he felt was appropriate amount.
Well, I don't know that no other lawyer
had ever asked a jury
for a billion dollars.
However, our case is unique
in that we really supported that number
through the enormity of the
abuses that had occurred.
And the amount that the
jury ultimately awarded
to the Marcos class
totaled almost two billion.
That was astronomical figure,
an absolutely unheard of figure.
It was the largest ever personal
injury judgment in history.
So immediately upon receiving
the monetary judgements
in 1994 and 1995, Swift got to work
and started assessing what
things they could try to claim.
This was very challenging in part
because the Philippines' courts
did not recognize the U.S. judgment,
and so they couldn't go after
any assets in the Philippines.
They had to go after assets elsewhere.
In effect, I was limited to executing
on whatever Marcos' assets
were in the United States,
and of course, the
Marcoses weren't willing
to testify as to that.
I took their depositions several times,
and they claimed they
didn't know anything.
Of course, that was false.
So the turning point as it relates
to collections was between 2000 and 2010.
And essentially, what happened was there
was an oil investor in Texas
by the name of Alan Meeker,
and he found some
attractive parcels of land
that he was interested in purchasing.
But for the life of him,
the way that he describes it
was he couldn't find the darn owner.
And as he was doing due
diligence on this land,
he remembered a rumor that he
had heard when he was younger
that Ferdinand Marcos had
actually purchased a bunch
of oil producing lands in Texas.
These lands proved to be very valuable
and ultimately was able
to settle that litigation
for $10 million.
So Swift was absolutely overjoyed
at the prospect of finally
having enough money
to distribute to the class members
who had waited for so many decades
to see anything after the judgements came.
But the challenges were
still very great in terms
of how the money would
actually get distributed.
So while I had 10,000
checks with names on them,
many of the people had died.
By that, I mean more than 20%.
So the process was
laborious and much slower
than I would've liked,
but it was very effective,
and it was also gratifying.
The faces of the people
expressing their gratitude
were enough of a reward that I felt good
about what we were doing,
and I knew that it was gonna benefit them.
I would often ask people
frequently through an interpreter,
"How are you going to use the money?"
And I was told that they would use it
to put a cemetery stone by the
church for their loved one,
or they would send their
children to school,
or they would simply buy food.
The older people would use the money
to buy prescription drugs
that they couldn't otherwise afford.
10 years, I'm starting to rise again.
Now like a phoenix,
hopefully, the truth will come
from the ashes of what was done to us.
Ferdinand Marcos and
his family were exiled
from the Philippines in the 1980s,
but subsequent to his death,
they were allowed to return.
And since then, they have managed
to really regain the popularity
that they enjoyed during his term.
Congratulations, Senator Imee Marcos.
Well, it's outrageous
that the nation allows this to happen.
Will I say sorry for the power generation?
Will I say sorry for the
highest literacy rate in Asia?
What am I to say sorry about?
In the Philippines, as in other countries,
elections are frequently won by those
who can more readily distribute money
during the election process.
The Marcoses have had access
to the monies acquired
and hidden by Ferdinand Marcos.
The richest
is Senator Ferdinand Marcos, Jr.,
who declared a net worth of
more than 400 million pesos.
Bongbong Marcos, his son,
is running for president
in 2022 and is polling quite well.
I'm confident that some of the money
that was acquired by Ferdinand
Marcos and hidden is going
to find its way into the 2022
election in the Philippines.